cuando escuchamos el término constante
de proporcionalidad puede parecernos un
poco intimidante y sonar muy técnico
pero veremos que es un concepto bastante
intuitivo vamos a resolver varios
ejemplos para familiarizarnos con él
imaginemos que tenemos una pastelería y
queremos preparar unos pastelitos
dependiendo de la cantidad de pastelitos
que queremos preparar para cierta
cantidad de huevos tenemos que usar el
doble de tazas de leche podemos decir
que las tazas de leche son iguales a 2
por el número de huevos que vamos a
ocupar cuál creen que sea aquí la
constante de proporcionalidad pues va a
ser igual a 2 esta es una relación
proporcional entre las tazas de leche y
el número de huevos las tasas de leche
siempre serán iguales a 2 por el número
de huevos si conocemos el número de
huevos a ocupar lo vamos a multiplicar
por la constante de proporcionalidad
para encontrar la cantidad de tazas de
leche a usar podemos ver con mayor
claridad porque esta es una constante de
proporcionalidad si hacemos una tabla en
una columna ponemos el número de huevos
y en otra columna ponemos el número de
tazas de leche si tenemos un huevo
cuántas tazas de leche se van a
necesitar
lo multiplicamos por 2 y nos da 2 tazas
de leche si tenemos tres huevos lo vamos
a multiplicar por dos para calcular el
número de tazas de leche y vemos que es
igual a 6 si tuviéramos que usar un
millón de huevos quizá tendremos una
megafiesta o un encargo para una
panadería industrial cuántas tazas de
leche tendremos que usar pues
sustituimos un millón acá lo
multiplicamos por dos y tenemos que son
dos millones de tazas de leche podemos
ver que esta es una relación
proporcional porque para pasar de número
de huevos a tazas de leche tenemos que
multiplicar los huevos por 2 cada vez
tal como nos indica la ecuación siempre
que multiplicamos el número de huevos
por cierta cantidad también
multiplicamos el número de tazas de
leche por la misma cantidad si
multiplicamos el número de huevos por un
millón también multiplicamos el número
de tazas de leche por un millón esto
claramente es una relación de
proporcionalidad veamos otro ejemplo
para practicar cómo identificar la
constante de proporcionalidad imaginemos
algo un poco más abstracto aquí tenemos
una variable a que es igual a 5 que
multiplica a otra variable cuál es
la constante de proporcionalidad en este
ejemplo pausa en el vídeo y traten de
responder a esto por su cuenta
efectivamente la respuesta es 5 si
conocemos el valor debe lo multiplicamos
por 5 para encontrar el valor de a
hagamos otro ejemplo ahora ya es igual a
pi por x cuál es la constante de
proporcionalidad aquí si nos dan el
valor de x lo vamos a multiplicar por el
número que está aquí que en este caso es
pin para encontrar el valor de jeff en
este caso la constante de
proporcionalidad espn veamos un ejemplo
más digamos que ya es igual a un medio
por x cuál es la constante de
proporcionalidad pausa en el vídeo y
piensen en ello nuevamente este es el
número que va a multiplicar a x para
encontrar el valor de y es igual a un
medio en general podemos encontrar la
constante de proporcionalidad de esta
forma y es igual acá por x donde k es la
constante de proporcionalidad en este
caso k es igual a un medio aquí arriba
acá es igual a pi con esto terminamos y
nos vemos en el siguiente vídeo